what's happening man it's your boy A.D
man I'm back over here catch me on a
bootleg calf podcast right now hit the
link
bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here my guy A.D what's the deal blue
ain't Cavs man welcome man happy to be
back man yeah last time you came moves
with Adam get you back here by yourself
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well first
of all man I'm super proud of you bro
I'm super proud of you this guy I
remember this guy uh
every night of the week would be at a
nightclub somewhere in the country yep
somehow I was like I was just always so
impressed at your ability to be
everywhere
you were like outside outside I put more
time into going out than putting in work
than your music career for sure
everything yo do you think everything do
you think you catching that record juice
like was a gift in a curse but you
caught one and then it was like over
because you were just like everywhere I
wouldn't say it's a gift and a curse I
just feel like I got super lucky and I
didn't know what to do after that so I
was like [ __ ] it let the good times roll
dude that record was so hard and then
you you cut bro you cut like the hardest
dub plates for DJs a million of them
bootleg I've got the juice but that's
shout out to uh DJ head because he's the
one who told me to give him a custom one
then I was like oh I'm gonna make one
for everybody but I play that [ __ ]
everywhere yeah because I was like it
says my name in it bro it was like such
a perfect like
that's that's like a la staple record a
definitely you got a few I got a few I
got some more coming I ain't done well
listen you obviously a lot of people
more recently know you as a personality
for sure but you are a veteran La rapper
and I've been [ __ ] with you and
supporting you for
it's been a long time probably eight or
nine years oh yeah getting close to a
decade yeah yeah
um but just to see you kind of like
because you've always had a great
personality
I think you came on our show freestyle
once and brought a wig I did I pulled
the wick out and that was actually my
baby Mama's wig yeah you pull the [ __ ]
it all down you pulled the weave out bro
yeah man but you've always had like this
personality so it's just dope to see you
kind of like Embrace that [ __ ] you know
what I mean because I feel like there's
like
did you feel like you were fighting any
sort of stigma or hesitation to like
dive all the way in with that because oh
hell yeah I mean look the thing is is
like
when you people put their own
insecurities on you and stuff like that
you know what I'm saying they put their
own projections on you and
um I just I'm just happy that I've
always been the person that listened to
myself so even when I said I wanted to
be a rapper you know my family at the
time they were like okay I'm not mad at
them for that but they couldn't see it
right you know what I mean like they it
didn't make sense to them it was like
wait a minute he's just gonna you're
gonna rap and you're gonna make it
you're gonna do this you're gonna do
that so it's just like [ __ ] I was
living at my granny house I was 25 26
right so you know your family looking at
you like man man listen you grown get a
job right you feel me I got my baby mama
living there my daughter right under we
Under One Roof and I'm just sitting
there telling them just having that
self-belief and having that faith that
something's gonna work and then
something did work and you know that
pivot me you know doing music and you
know while that was going on you know I
felt like I got I kind of got to a a
ceiling where it was just like damn the
[ __ ] ain't getting no bigger and I'm
watching this [ __ ] decline but still
Keeping the Faith because you know I I'm
like something is going to pop up and
then the no jumper [ __ ] happened
randomly right I'm just sure you went in
an interview right and then it went well
bro almost everything in my life that's
been very successful for me like it
randomly happened and I know it's not
random you feel me that's all God but it
just randomly happened like a lot of
[ __ ] I didn't plan for yeah because uh
for you because like were there people
your music industry friends that were
like yo man once you kind of go that
direction
there's no coming back everybody
everybody told me it's a bad decision
you need to focus more on your music you
need to do this you need to do this and
you do that and I'm just like okay and
I'm gonna keep it real with you when
Adam first approached me he was you know
I was supposed to just do the Snapchat
show I wasn't even I wasn't even
supposed to be full-time right I was
just gonna do it
covet happened once it happened
they was like do you want to keep doing
it so I thought I was going to be able
to stay under the radar doing a Snapchat
show because I'm like no one's [ __ ]
on Snapchat I'm like I don't know yeah
nobody in this industry that was
actively on Snapchat at the time so I'm
like okay I can skate under the rug with
this with the Snapchat [ __ ] and then you
know still do my music don't nobody know
and then I just started from the
Snapchat show I just started seeing
people just recognize me and they would
come up to me like I like watching you
on Snapchat like younger kids and [ __ ]
and I'm like what the [ __ ] right and
these all different raised people and
I'm like wait a minute this is you know
different yeah and they just coming up
to me coming up to me and then I started
subbing on a no jumper show and just the
the amount of people that was just
[ __ ] with me I was like damn like
this [ __ ] is dope it's a little
different yeah and then you know that
turned into what it turned into but I
mean now everybody says oh you're a
genius for what you did I'm like [ __ ]
you the same [ __ ] who told me right
don't do that that was a dumb decision
you know what I mean and now I see
everybody now everyone in there bro let
me tell you something bro it's so funny
because even now like I have people who
are like
people you wouldn't expect to want to
start their own podcast trust me right
and they call me and they're like hey
man look I'm trying to do a podcast I'm
like you're trying to do a punk like
it's it's just to the point where like
I feel like it's like with anything once
people see it really because like look
can you tell me this without getting
into your business too much have you
made more money as a personality than as
a rapper
12 15 times more money as a personality
okay I'll say this
four years it took me four to five years
to get a monthly check with music that I
can you know survive off of that ain't
going extra or anything like that I
passed that up my third week of doing my
streams I mean my third month for
Community yeah wow past three years up
because you were like getting advances
at ever I feel like you have an album at
every distribution [ __ ] I had bro I
feel like you were bouncing around
grabbing [ __ ] bags I mean I needed it
yeah no I know but I remember I forget
me and you were talking and I was like
yo are you on Empire and you're like I'm
On Everything [ __ ] we got some [ __ ] on
Foundation we got bro Foundation Empire
um
um shout out to fuzzy we did a deal with
priorities
we did everything under the sun you know
I mean so it took you three months to of
doing your own [ __ ] not even the no
jumpership not even no jumpership right
my second month of the community I seen
the check and I said what the [ __ ] wow
it was it was Game Changer it was
life-changing
now for people who do the the or want to
do the streaming thing right there's a
different app that you obviously are on
caffeine now child together but what for
you did you notice was the most before
caffeine came into the picture uh was it
YouTube or twitch that was more
well my goal was and you know shout out
to Ace boy pun
um pun bought me a white board and he
was like you know what because we
started seeing the no jumpership was
really working and you know Adam gave me
my show uh once Adam gave me the show we
start seeing the numbers and everything
climbing everything started happening
and then
I tried twitch three times before it
worked so at first I just wanted to play
video games and just I was like I'm good
at video games I started playing
fortnite at my crib at my old apartment
and you know I just had my son right you
know I mean my son was probably like one
years old my son's running around I
don't got no nice background I'm doing a
twitch thing 12 people coming right so I
get discouraged I sell all the equipment
then we came up with a plan with a was
shout out to Seaside stretch shout out
the wheel we was like all right we gonna
turn this streaming [ __ ] to something
dope we wanna we wanna got a spot bought
a stripper pole we bought all type of
equipment and me and all miles Parish we
ended up teaming up because he was he
already was a partner on Twitch
um so we teamed up and we started doing
that every Monday we was calling it The
Monday show and
I think the most we had was like 30
people watching us get discouraged again
sell the equipment was that after you
did no jumper yeah this is why the man
no jumper like I do remember the miles
Parish thing yeah so we we started that
but it's like it wasn't it wasn't moving
at the pace where I felt like it was
worth committing to every month and I
ended up um getting my new crib and I
was looking for a three bedroom and the
crib was actually four bedrooms and I
looked at the bottom and I said this is
a whole bedroom the other bedrooms on
the third floor it's all the way from
each other I'm like this is the perfect
setup I'm like I gotta get this spot and
then right there I was like this is
where we're gonna put all the stuff
right here it's away from the bedrooms
nobody got to hear me make noise or do
anything like that my kids and yeah man
we sat in that room we got it and once
again I just wanted to play video games
and um the first time that we streamed
and it's been it's been one year we just
hit our one year anniversary I remember
when we did the corner store brunch I
think you guys just started just started
yeah and we were playing video games and
I seen what 200 people in there I was
like wow all right we on we on to
something now and then it it just
adapted because all I wanted to do and
on my whiteboard all I wanted to do was
get uh what was it
500 subscribers just for the year yeah I
was like you know poem was like we're
gonna start small we're gonna build this
up we're gonna do this and do that and
it went from playing video games because
they just started asking me questions
while I'm playing the video game and I'm
like hey
they're like hey what about this they
had to start asking me questions and I
just start answering so then I'm like
they don't even want to see me play
video games so now they wanted me to
just to talk and do topics and stuff and
you know we started implementing them
freestyling we just just showing their
personality yeah just just shooting the
[ __ ] and them numbers just started just
started shooting up and then we didn't
even want to do YouTube I just said we
switch twitch twist twist twitch shout
out to our moderator Clint Lowe quinlow
was like I could turn your stuff into
clips from your streams and then we were
like okay whatever
he started you know making the clips we
started seeing like damn people are
really watching the Clips on YouTube and
then you know shout out to him he gave
us ownership of it and he you know
that's my moderator he works for us now
um he gave us ownership of the page of
the channel because he made the channel
he made the channel just on some like
just like on some on some like just you
know he was a a fan of why you know
there's a lot of those there's a lot of
those like Joe Rogan and no jumper
channels too like that on YouTube he uh
he gave us ownership of it and then um
yeah bro we started we started making
some real chili and then that second
month the first month I was like okay
this is nice the second month I was like
whoa I was blown back I was like I never
made this much money
in one month ever in my life so T
Grizzly made 115 Grand in one month he
showed me on his phone what's your best
month
not getting into any numbers no get into
some numbers
I want to say overall this is what
everything combined content-wise I would
say close to like
50 60 in a month yes that's what
everything combined you feel me yeah
that's beautiful man yeah
hey what UPS bootleg cab here to stop
the interview and tell you about
Bluetooth yes do you have a dick does
your husband have a dick
maybe does your boyfriend got a dick
does your wife have a dick who knows
um it could be harder I'll tell you that
yeah Bluetooth gets your dick real hard
to kick off that new year you know what
I'm saying if you want your dick harder
than
Advanced trigonometry senior year high
school then go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg and get
one month supply for free that's right
free all you got to do is pay five
dollars in shipping
they're going to deliver the blue chew
right to your [ __ ] door and discreet
packaging all right same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis
in a chewable form
very discreet packaging mailed to your
house you don't have to go to a doctor's
appointment in person with anybody you
don't have to worry about embarrassing
conversations with strangers about your
[ __ ] dick bro nobody wants to talk
about their dick with a stranger I take
that back I take that back
lots of people like to talk about their
dicks with strangers
if you're not that kind of guy or girl
or them all you gotta do is go to
Bluetooth right now and use the promo
code
bootleg and you're gonna get it sent
straight to your door that's right they
also got the new mint chewable that's
the same active ingredients as Levitra
so there's a lot of options to get your
dick right in the New Year it's 2023.
yeah your dick shouldn't be flaccid
after a like nice long stressful night
no your dick should be ready you don't
want to be a you know a victim of too
much stress too much anxiety and then
you look down and you can't stay hard
you imagine how [ __ ] embarrassing
that is you get yourself a nice lovely
[ __ ] young lady you bring her to the
place you're nervous she's a little
maybe she's a little out of your [ __ ]
league and you start thinking too much
and that dick's not gonna perform it's
not it's not going to perform how you'd
like it to but you know how it will
perform if you're on that [ __ ]
Bluetooth
you're gonna put in a [ __ ] Luka
donkic 61 Point [ __ ] performance on
that [ __ ] all right so go to
bluetooth.com right now use that promo
code bootleg let's get back to the
interview because I always wonder
because I I I think I told you I I told
because I I feel like UNT rail
oh shout out to back on fig Muni my
brother I feel like you guys
are very much
um when I look at like drink Champs on
the East Coast I feel like you guys are
you guys can be that uh over here for
sure because I feel like you guys are
are very
um
you guys each have your own connections
not only to obviously the rap game but
also just to the street side and I feel
like you guys are both very reasonable
guys as to where most people who come
from like a [ __ ] background or a Hoover
background there's not a lot of Reason
like like I feel like you guys have you
have you guys ever like the the thought
process of like what if the no jumper
thing goes away tomorrow are you guys
like has that ever been like a oh we a
team you know shout out to smack too we
pushing this whole big Community line
you feel me that's gonna go you know
beyond just what we do and other stuff
too and one thing I like about t-real is
um
he's he's just like he's a parallel with
me yeah meaning like people known him as
being the best friends of certain
popping artists you know what I'm saying
people kind of know you as the guy with
OT exactly and Trey Songz and Joe Moses
and Wiz Khalifa yeah
yeah like shooting Feats yeah yeah yeah
I mean you neither here or there you
feel me but no I've always been a number
two guy for sure and I've embraced that
because I'm like I'm one of the people
where if I see my homeboy is sitting
here doing dope [ __ ] if I can assist him
in any type of way I'm cool I can play
the background because he once again
goes back to having that faith and
knowing like you know I always knew
you're going to be in position you're
going to be number one it doesn't matter
when it's going to happen right but
you're going to be number one so you
know I see my brothers they need some
assistance I'ma help them out I'm gonna
be hype man I'm gonna I'm gonna do the
social media [ __ ] at one point in time I
was posting all Joe Moses [ __ ] you feel
me I was hype man for him I'm some you
know when he ain't never whip you feel
me me and him thugging it out my baby
mama car we driving around everywhere
same as OT we taking the whip we going
places and that's the type of person I
am so I feel like t-rail too you know
he's always been a number two guy and we
know what it's like when you not really
around them certain artists no more how
a [ __ ] change on you how they
start looking how they look at you it's
like nah [ __ ] if you're not around your
homeboy we don't want nothing to do with
you you know what I'm saying you felt
that yeah I felt that before I just feel
like everyone loves you yeah but you
know the DJs but it was certain
individuals were like nah they wasn't
really [ __ ] with me it was cool it
wasn't no beef right but like to wear
how I used to see people and they would
show me super super love it wasn't like
that but people always remember like man
you always been a cool guy so as they
see me coming up they like okay you know
we'll [ __ ] with them we'll [ __ ] with
them and [ __ ] like that has OT thought
about doing a podcast he's not thought
about doing a pod but I recently had him
on some streams and he's been loving it
so I've been like I've literally for a
whole year been trying to convince him
[ __ ] because he loves Madden I'm like
[ __ ] get a set up and just talk your
[ __ ] because out of everybody in this
industry OT probably got one of the best
personalities of all he's hilarious
hilarious and people don't I feel like
because OT doesn't drop albums he just
drops songs
OT has one of the weirdest rap careers
ever yes because this guy has [ __ ]
hit records hit records but he doesn't
put out any bodies of work no he just
throws out these moments and then he
goes away or or no then he goes to the
club but you know like or he'll pop up
on like an RJ album or something but
it's like it's crazy all the records
sold and he I think he's put out one
project is he's he's yet
to surprise me when it comes down to
that [ __ ] like back then like I swear to
God I remember when he first got his
deal
and he had got a large Advance yeah and
we were going to the which time the
first time when it was not with G Unit I
don't know that was unit when he first
signed with uh
the conglomerate thing yeah man listen
he had got this advance and we were
going to the club and I'm watching I'm
like bro you're spending too much money
and he's telling me when you coming or
what I'm like I'm coming bro but I'm a
homeboy
bro this is a lot of money you spending
we we're going to the club 10-15 minutes
before it closed okay give me some Don
P's like give me this We're not gonna
finish these bottles and I'm like listen
at this time I'm like you haven't
produced a record yet for these people
you know what I'm saying and he's like
bro I got it
sure enough it was a it was a video and
I think this song was called yum yum we
were at the Yum Yum video shoot and
you know I feel like the label was
probably like okay he's not doing
nothing you feel me that man took his
own money
he did Coco took his own money shot his
own video shot his own video and the
[ __ ] went viral yeah and I watched that
yeah I watched that and I and my dumb
ass was supposed to be in the video
ended up getting getting there super
late I came at the tail end of it and
I'm like God damn [ __ ] missed that
Viral moment I feel like OT
is one of those artists that we look at
as his music is bigger than him
but I feel like if he did a podcast or
he was like because he's so funny bro if
you ever look at his Instagram stories
bro and that's that's where I get the
[ __ ] from he's just a maniac he's
hilarious that's why I get this [ __ ]
from his Instagram stories are so
[ __ ] calculated and like it's so
entertaining or just him [ __ ] walking
his yeah his crib I mean you're by the
way you're terrible [ __ ] walker uh yeah
big you killed me off yeah if you're
gonna shout out to Big you man big you
that's kind of the reason why I'll be
[ __ ] walking no more I get you shouldn't
no yes big you called me on a bad day I
was listen I'm gonna tell you all this
too I was at a lingerie party you feel
me and I hit by the time you went viral
yes yes okay I had to tuxedo on I had
the hard bottoms on I was drunk as [ __ ]
yeah and I start trying to walk slurring
and and big you recorded it and then put
it on the internet and yeah my
seawalking days is over yeah it's only
in private team man yes salute the bro
um I think uh for you I feel like you're
I mean Adam definitely acknowledges this
you kind are responsible for like the
pivot in no jumper being like a universe
you were like the first guy to come in
and be like I guess maybe change up the
business model a bit in terms of like
now you can do interviews yeah you know
what I mean like and then just I feel
like bringing in different personalities
because it's now no jumper
I watched the uh interview you guys did
with the Rory and Maul
and you guys are just a lot of game man
because you know our [ __ ] is guest based
but you know I got my radio so I got so
much [ __ ] going on but it is very true
what y'all were saying that like now you
guys don't have to do interviews anymore
all of the content is really just about
y'all like bro I dived into this [ __ ]
poetic Flaco [ __ ] Rabbit Hole
yesterday on your guys's clip Channel
and Shout out the Vlog it's all just
[ __ ] about like y'all like you guys have
built this [ __ ] crazy Universe like
is there is there like when you have the
seniority over everybody but like do you
get paid per like episode like how it
performs are you like on a salary like
at no jump it's a it's it's it's some of
both because I have the food show there
too which is fire when you guys reach
the Holland race that [ __ ] was fun oh
bro I've watched I've watched almost all
of them yeah that's that's you know and
I mean that stop was on the phone in
that [ __ ] episode that's not the one
that said like anything Armenian own
esta Helen rays
whoa whoa
shout out to hella Rays no very
surprised
is dope though because you know I don't
know why Adam believed to me you know
what I'm saying but he gave me free
reign to basically do what I want to do
he's trusted some of the people I
suggested to come to the platform
um Beyond even when you're on camera
people we sometimes they be like I don't
like each other and stuff like that like
the [ __ ] literally just set up another
game-changing play for me behind the
scenes that has nothing to do with no
jumper fire so it's like you know he
he's not one of the people that holds
the wealth he'll spread it to you and
stuff like that too and so I appreciate
him you know he's family forever now he
definitely seems like uh you know I've
talked to Adam a lot and I always tell
people like
he's like a nice guy dude like he's a
grinch though no but I'm saying like
dude even four or five years ago when I
was like originally gonna launch my
podcast like he pulled up to my house
and did an interview with me in my
basement and it was like it he's always
been a very giving dude at least from
what I perceive if he [ __ ] with you he
[ __ ] with you for sure if you don't
like you he's going to ignore he's going
to ignore you you know what I'm saying
like and it's been it's been people on
the team that said hey bro hey man I
used to hit you up
I ditched you you know what I'm saying
like he was like I didn't see it people
like on their jumpers wow yeah like
Almighty suspect or somebody
I ain't saying no names shout out to
suspect it is kind of crazy though like
just some of the intertwinings of like
the drama you somehow always are uh very
uh you're like Switzerland you're very
neutral with everybody and that there's
so much craziness going on in that no
jumper building I mean you gotta you
gotta understand it's like well you know
my my background in in LA with the
politics and stuff like that I just feel
like a lot of people you know certain
situations ain't that serious and if I
can intervene and you know what I'm
saying make that [ __ ] help help that
situation then I'm gonna do that because
you know I know what it's like to come
from different [ __ ] in different
circumstances so now that I'm in
position over here I don't want nothing
to [ __ ] that up right and a lot of times
something somebody else does can affect
the whole team you know what I'm saying
it can affect the money and I'm like hey
[ __ ] don't cut the [ __ ] my money you
[ __ ] my money now I ain't no more
neutral nothing it's it's a whole nother
ball game yeah because I even look at
like the way you handled the Flacco
thing like yesterday you were talking
like you were you were kind of being
sympathetic to his mental health bro
because as a person who've had mental
health issues you know what I'm saying
if you ever watch me I'll always talk
about that like I've had super severe
anxiety you know what I'm saying
um once I stopped drinking hard liquor
man for like three four months I was I
was super depressed
um you know having insomnia like I just
feel like I was at a a [ __ ] terrible
point in my life and I know mentally a
lot of times man especially for somebody
like Flaco he's from North Dakota he you
know he don't he doesn't look like us he
doesn't act like us he does things that
are different but that you know he has
he takes so much [ __ ] hate and it's
like I think it I think it all really
started once he uh he had that uh moment
with that dude who spit in his face and
you were sitting there like
I didn't sign up for this [ __ ]
like
a situation like that is like you gotta
think about that you get spit on you
feel me got everybody talking about you
all the time yeah for sure and it's like
that [ __ ] got feelings too you feel me
and we don't know mentally what he's
going through he seems like a nice guy
and I'm like you know God forbid
something happened to this man or he
felt like he can't take it no more you
feel me yeah I want to at least be like
you know I'm somebody that was nice to
you you feel me and I joke on them too
like I say certain things to him I call
him I joke on them I play around I troll
him too we all do that [ __ ] but at the
end of the day it's not to be malicious
and you know I I care about him and I
care about everybody on the team yo what
up we gotta stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family over
at my bookie that's right with lots
going on in basketball right now Lots
going on in the NFL playoffs are about
to start Super Bowls coming up so much
to gamble on let's win some money go to
my bookie right now if you sign up for a
new account mybookie.ag
you can gamble from wherever you're at
yes go to my bookie and use the promo
code bootleg when you sign up for that
new account and they will match your
first deposit up to one thousand dollars
that's free money in your pocket uh that
you can gamble with so if you put a
thousand bucks in your account they're
gonna give you another thousand dollars
to gamble with so go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up with that
new account one more time they will
match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars all right so like maybe
you want to put 200 bucks on the Cowboys
or some [ __ ] to win the Super Bowl
you're gonna lose that money because
[ __ ] the Cowboys but let's say you do
want to put some money on the Cowboys
you sign up you put 200 they give you
another 200. on top of that free money
to gamble with is called the double
deposit bonus and you can only get it by
using the promo code bootleg so go to my
bookie right now sign up for an account
let's get back to the interview were you
going to be a part of the uh Kanye West
interview that didn't happen yeah
was that that was the Nick Fuentes thing
uh-huh so shout out to my guy guilty so
guilty is a guy behind the scenes I
don't know how he does it but he he
contacts everybody he's put he's put a
lot of this stuff together the first
Nick Fuentes interview he actually uh I
was gonna say that was kind of a weird
because I didn't know anything about
Nick Fuentes and I've seen you guys talk
about like how like you know we probably
you know it probably wasn't the most
productive conversation no I didn't know
anything about this dude and I just saw
I think I saw Adam talking about it
somewhere just like people are gonna be
pissed about this I was like oh let me
see what the who the [ __ ] this guy is I
was like oh this guy's kind of like a
he's kind of like a white nationalist
no but even even that situation that
showed me like
you have to I have to do my due
diligence and I before you talk to
anybody to talk to anybody you know like
I just a lot of times I get to just use
my personality and Coast on certain
stuff and I'm not even putting myself in
a situation where I gotta hold it down
for my culture and I have to hold it
down for my people being an
African-American man so if somebody has
viewpoints and they're sitting there
saying some stuff to me and I don't know
how to counter that you know it's kind
of like a letdown for my whole community
so that that first interview showed me
where it's like okay I need to be more
prepared and I just can't not study and
not you know get all the facts before I
jump in the ring with somebody like that
was that an interview that you you got
negative feedback from from like like
just like you said like did people think
you didn't do enough yeah they like
they're like you should have said this
you should have known this you should
have known that and I agree I'm like
yeah I I I should have did way better
when it came down to that because you
know not knowing the history like that's
not no excuse right I have all these
resources I'm in position people look up
to me and I feel like I got to be a good
representation for them so if somebody's
coming at my people or saying certain
certain things like I got to be able to
count it and do an intelligently so when
the Kanye thing was about to happen oh I
did you were ready I was studying for
like three days didn't nobody know I
didn't tell nobody but I literally was a
deep diving getting all my facts
together because I'm like if anybody say
anything I'm about to I'm about to be
there what ended up happening just they
just didn't pull up I think Kanye just
canceled on everybody yeah yeah yeah
yeah so it's crazy that would have been
a legendary it would have been legendary
um do you feel like because I feel like
with your relationships
in hip-hop you have yet to in my opinion
really like lean on them too much for
guests because I know the people who
you're super tight with and like out of
those guys like I know you've had whiz
on you had OT on but like you got other
guys that like a lot you probably could
have pulled Tori on if you really wanted
to before a lot betray we could go on
and on and on but like is that something
that you try to kind of keep separate to
where you're like look these are my
friendships and if it happens it's gonna
be organic it's I'm not gonna like Hawk
somebody to try to come on the show I've
never
uh even with whiz whiz hit me up was
like hey you still doing podcasts I want
to come on here yeah OT like I want to
come on here it's like
I don't want to like put that in the air
you feel me it's like you know if you
see it if you see what's going on and
you want to come on I rather you do that
versus me like hey bro do this favor for
me because let's keep it real that's
what all these [ __ ] do anyway all they
do is get the things bro can you do this
for me can you do this for me can you do
this for me can you do this for me it's
like nah I want to be one of the people
it's like [ __ ] I want to when we
friends we friends we're gonna hang out
we're gonna turn up we're gonna do that
that's our relationship we keep that
[ __ ] separate that's a beautiful thing
yeah what's for you like what was the
one time you guys you've done an
interview so far where you feel like you
you kind of hit your
you know doing interviews like rapping
you get better you know what I mean but
what was kind of for you like the peak
interview where you were like oh I felt
most comfortable this was my best
conversation
um you wanna know this crazy shout out
to my guy 19 Keys you feel me I think
that was like one of the ones where I
was like oh this is dope but you know
one thing people don't know you usually
don't see me interviewing nobody that's
true you know I mean I usually co-host
on a lot of the interviews with Adam are
all doing with T-Rex or they're a guest
on yeah yeah oh there's a guest on the
show so and the reason being I have so
many relationships you know smaller
scale to higher scale I already know
what that [ __ ] is going to be one of my
favorites was the mozzie combo yeah it
was like it was like it was it was like
but it's natural it was natural it
wasn't like an interview it was like he
was just a part of your guys I just want
you to come you want to come sit down
with ad I want you to come kick it be
yourself I'm not gonna ask you know
incriminating [ __ ] I ain't gonna ask you
know weird [ __ ] I want you to come have
a good time you feel me Smoke Drink do
what the [ __ ] you do loosen up and show
people a good side of you because like I
know like mozzie has a stigma on him
people he's crazy he's crazy he's crazy
he came on our show and just joke around
and people like damn I ain't never seen
mozzie like that so if I could put that
in the air then that's what that's what
it is do you find yourself if you're
friends with people and you know that
they have
pretty big issues with other people
because I I like the no jumper thing is
like I mean when when [ __ ] Mack was
coming up there a lot with Tyrell being
in the building it was just like I was
like yo that [ __ ] that shit's crazy like
this guy's got whatever he's got
tattooed on his [ __ ] forehead and
tyrell's a main host there like it just
it was crazy do you find yourself like
turning down [ __ ] or not being a part of
certain [ __ ] maybe because of the
relationships you have outside of being
uh I mean loyalty is always going to be
number one in my book before anything
like I don't care about
[ __ ] like that but you know Tyrell is
grown enough and he doesn't care do you
feel me if you know if if [ __ ] Mack
wasn't how he is Tyrell probably
wouldn't have no problem sitting down
with him he sat down with odm Slim Right
and I thought that that was super big
for the culture in the street today
yeah like [ __ ] like that is super dope
so Tyrell has it to where he's looking
at the bigger picture of where he wants
to be placed in in his history and CMAC
is just c-mac you feel me he stands on
this [ __ ] he you know he is he is who he
is and that's why people love him so I
mean situations like that are always
going to conflict and I don't get in the
middle of that but loyalty wise like I
got a rock with my with my guys right or
wrong yeah have you turned down an
interview because you just kind of knew
maybe somebody you're friend with might
feel some type of way
um not turn down the interview I just
don't be there right I was just like hey
if somebody else wouldn't do it y'all
can do it I'm not gonna be a part of it
yeah
yeah like that's like right now you my
guy right I [ __ ] with you I can't
somebody that that blatantly hates you
you feel me like or or is this super
going crazy on you I can't sit there and
call you my friend and go sit down with
him or facilitate something knowing that
he's about to say something bad about
you right I'll be a fake ass [ __ ] for
that that's fair uh you and uh
first of all shout out to China Mac oh
my God because you guys had a very
interesting altercation where you guys
shot the fair fade and now you guys are
[ __ ] making content together you you
inspired him to get his twitch uh his
streaming equipment going smart guy
um to me that's like a situation where
it's like this is how like
issues should be resolved in hip-hop
just in general man being a man yeah
like you guys [ __ ] got it in kept it
moving and and I feel like people needed
to see that right you know what I mean
and it's crazy that like a lot of people
praised that situation when it's not
really a big situation right it's like
okay [ __ ] got down they did they [ __ ]
and they said some normal [ __ ] it's some
normal [ __ ] well you know but it's like
you know people are so used to like okay
we're gonna slide on him we're gonna do
this we're gonna do that and it's like
listen you can have a dispute and you
know you don't have to go down the blows
all the time let that be the last resort
that's the last resort Last Resort let
that be violence but just in case you
have a dispute with somebody y'all can
sit there and patch that up and if it
can't be handled with words go ahead and
knuckle it up real quick and shake hands
and keep your [ __ ] pushing because you
know a situation like that China Mac is
is one of my dogs he can come to my
house whenever he wants to we about to
start filming other type of content you
know what I'm saying and doing [ __ ]
together so you know what I mean you
know he's killing it too his Mac eat
[ __ ] is amazing fire it's amazing yeah
when you uh do the food show with duno
uh how do you get like how do you guys
pick the restaurants like is it like
we we haven't done a Mexican spot let's
do a Mexican spot we haven't done a hot
chicken spot let's
shout out to S dog because he's been
helping us out a lot with that too and
[ __ ] it and going forward we about to
have a more um you guys got to go to
rafi's [ __ ] just get the whole
Armenian [ __ ] experience that stop
put on for your [ __ ] people bro he
took me to he took me to a gang of spots
but now we're about to um we're about to
do things a little more differently
we're going to film everything way
um more structured because I feel like
by the time that we gotta pick a place
we do it it takes too much time to
produce and I feel like if it was more
frequent then more people will be
watching it which is doing amazing don't
get me wrong sure but now we're going to
break it down into like seasons and then
take a whole week to film all the
content and spread that out and break it
down yeah because you guys drop what is
it once a month maybe it's not even that
sometimes yeah it's not very consistent
no but sure you know we have the spots
it's just you know the editing team man
is is so much content they have to edit
and they do on top of our [ __ ] but every
time we drop the views have been amazing
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
hardean that's right hard Dean Las Vegas
the craziest dispensary in the world the
number one dispensary in the United
States let alone in Las Vegas all right
maybe you're hitting Vegas with your
friends your girlfriends whatever maybe
it's a bachelor party whatever's going
on you're going to go watch the Raiders
suck [ __ ] whatever it is make sure you
pull up to Hardy in Las Vegas tell them
I sent you they got the craziest
selection of Premium cannabis I've ever
seen in my [ __ ] life the pre-rolls
the cartridges the Edibles the flower
all Top Notch all the best the bud
tenders are so friendly it smells great
it smells so good inside a Jardine that
they have their own Harding signature
scent candle
see I sniff that and I just think of Las
Vegas and picking up some amazing weed
alright so go follow them right now
Jardine underscore Las Vegas shoot them
a follow get all the details you need
you can get you some of this fire ass
Jardine merch at hardinglasvegas.com
shout out to our family in Vegas I'm
excited too because coming up we're
going to be doing our very first podcast
from Jardin in Vegas with young gravy oh
yeah it's going down all right let's get
back to the interview that's amazing
how's it doing live podcasting live
podcasting is fire yeah I'm surprised
you ain't did that [ __ ] yeah me and
Freddie talked about doing one bro it
was amazing especially like the you know
you get to you get to meet your core
audience right and you know they they
can scream out what the [ __ ] you want
like especially like
doing um streaming right it gets you
kind of equipped for that because you're
used to reading the chat and people
saying [ __ ] but it's the same thing
people in the crowd they have questions
they say [ __ ] and you go to the meet and
greet and people show you know I'm
saying show you so much love and [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] though what are you doing
on the rap side you've been putting out
some loosies you've been throwing some
singles out there here and there I got
some big [ __ ] going you once again I had
a [ __ ] I had some balances that had
to clear they clear now but you know me
and um
I'll just say if me and Don Cannon got a
whole project it's almost done we that's
he's producing the whole day oh wow the
Don County man
um shows uh Krishan you feel me shout
out to krashawn you know saying with
maker sound and all that yeah okay okay
okay bro I didn't know if you just told
me you're gonna drop a collab EP with
croshan rock or not no no
I'm gonna say [ __ ] no but you know just
you and Don well I I heard some records
um
somebody was playing I think it was
casting was playing me some oh yeah here
are some [ __ ] some [ __ ] that was like
crazy like just barring barring the [ __ ]
out it was like I was like [ __ ] but when
you hear me and Krishan [ __ ] shout out
to hit maker like yeah we got me a hit
maker croshan like this [ __ ] is out of
here would you do you feel like you're
doing like music now because you want to
not because you have to and it does the
music get better there
um no I just feel like now I don't have
to force [ __ ] out I could I can put out
quality Take Time versus quantity
because you know I don't have to live
off of music no more right but that
wasn't the goal was to be just
successful you know what I'm saying
something yeah something just be just be
successful so it's like now and then too
like I hate people putting that stigma
on that you can only be great at one
thing of course or you can only be you
know the face of this and doing that and
it's like I look up to Ice Cube I look
up to Donald Glover where I'm like man
listen like Donald Glover you see him do
stand up you see him you know producing
Atlanta
yeah yeah you could drop music you could
do that and it's and there's no ceiling
for him Ice Cube you feel me I mean you
were in Dave too yeah I was in Dave I'm
actually too man uh um if this comes out
in time I'm in the new house party movie
too I heard a lot of people shout out to
cow magic I heard a lot of people were
in that movie I'm in the movie and I got
a song in the movie I heard a lot of
people are in that movie yeah so are you
like are you gonna try to dive into that
side hell yeah okay if I'm doing
everything yeah I think you should write
a sitcoms I'm doing it oh bro I would
love to do a sitcom but yeah bro I just
feel like
the sky's the limit like there's nothing
I can't do and even right now people
like they're like bro you killing that
podcast you're killing it and streaming
like they may think this is my ceiling
this is not my ceiling right you feel me
I'm taking this [ __ ] even crazier put
you like if you if just being a fan of
the culture and having the friends you
have
who's somebody who hasn't thought about
doing a podcast who you think would just
[ __ ] destroy it if they ever got in
front of a mic and and did this [ __ ]
uh that's a good one
artists
I would have to say
honestly I think Gibbs would be [ __ ]
funny as [ __ ] for for a podcast well you
know we've we've talked again Gangsta
kids have talked about it over and over
and over oh so he thinking about it
we've yeah we've had our yeah we're me
and him were supposed to do something
like two years ago I think I think he
has the personality because he the way
he talks in general and how he tweets
and says certain things I think he'll be
good he's got to do it sober Freddie
drunk on camera
three episodes in he's canceled hey yes
yes but I I think like that'll be
entertaining and I'll watch that no
Freddie Gibbs would be amazing uh yeah
there's a few guys but Fred's Fred to me
is the one yeah for sure because he'd be
doing stand-up and [ __ ] and all that uh
how do you feeling about just La hip-hop
right now man because you were part of
an era that was like I think of you I
think RJ I think this that whole class
that was you guys are kind of like
veterans now which is kind of crazy but
you know I feel like LA right now is in
a place where
a lot more people are working together
than I feel like it used to be even
though they're still separation of
politics and all that man we got to but
you know I feel like a lot of these
younger kids are kind of like embracing
each other a little bit more than I've
you know seen in previous I guess uh
classes but how are you feeling about
work I think I think that you know and I
love all the new guys that are out you
feel me shout out to be know
um shout out to blast shout out to blue
bug shout out to Kalyn for real for real
Ruchi
um who am I miss who am I missing give
me some names one take Jay one take uh
AZ child yellow Hills dope oh yeah hey
yellow Hill is doing this thing it's
only a matter of time for yellow here
it's only a matter of time for yellow
um who am I missing who am I missing a
lot even Ralphie man Ralphie be killing
it I love I love Ralphie music you know
what I'm saying
um baby Stone gorillas
um you know what Perico's still holding
it down too you got to get Perico his
credit killing it he's killing you gotta
give him his credit
um
it's a it's a lot of it's a lot of dope
guys right here and shout out to the
[ __ ] in the IE team hey that's
somebody who could do a podcast Jeep
Rico Rico's funny as hell he's so funny
oh yeah no but I feel like now you know
how music translates now in the city is
way more harder because I was a hot new
hip-hop baby you feel me like I got
discovered on how new hip-hop right and
I had my you know when I felt like I
needed to drop albums they're right
there front page that piff right right
there how new hip hop and the discovery
for new artists now was just so [ __ ]
hard it's like everybody chasing Tick
Tock but they ain't really organic like
that you know what I'm saying chasing
that yeah you might catch a moment but
you ain't got no friends concert tickets
yeah and I mean now the club scene is so
[ __ ] dry it's whack and that's how we
got our records out there yeah for sure
you send me them supper clubs them
playhouses you'll be able to go to La
club and hear some [ __ ] and be like oh
what's this yeah everybody knows it
everybody knows and then you go back
home and you learning that [ __ ] but like
like and that's how like you know the
bookings and stuff like that that's what
kept us afloat yeah the club [ __ ] out
here I mean and listen I'm to the point
in my life where I don't go out unless
I'm getting paid or unless it's like an
event that it really makes sense for me
to go so I'm kind of like I just
remember like
I feel like since the pandemic the club
scene has yet to fully really rebound
the way it was for for like local La
hip-hop music I'd have been [ __ ] right
now I don't know like I I hear that
there's some spots like I know that the
LA function is cool to La function
Supreme Team Dragon
dragonfly too yeah but but I mean like
as far as the impact it's not there like
people used to play I want to go to LA
to go to supper
clubs yeah and right now on some fly
type [ __ ] I mean you know shout out to
my guy uh uh uh Scott I mean my guy um
um Sean my bad I said Scott uh
Wednesday's highlight room you feel me
yeah Dickerson Dickerson my guy Sean
Dickerson I said Scott what's that Sadiq
right Sadiq be booming yeah but that's
but that's not that's more that's not
nobody not a lot of people can get into
that no no no no nobody and they're not
playing no L.A music they're not playing
no la music no it's a Vibe it's a Vibe
though and you'll run into The Who's Who
of the world yeah but there's no like La
culture up there no but la culture-wise
like
I feel like
we all have to stick together now you'll
have to do music with each other now
you'll have to do concerts with each
other now because I'm loving all the
shows that have been happening at the
Roxy yeah it's been dope it's been super
dope I just talked to Caitlyn yesterday
he about to go back on tour shout out to
Caleb yeah we got a fire record coming
out oh that's gonna be the first thing I
drop coming back you and Katelyn me and
Kelly for real for real I think you've
been dropping records though you're here
and there yeah just a test of waters and
see how the climate is like yeah I mean
dude you're you're bigger than you've
ever been yeah so the music is gonna but
that's the that's the thing like if you
think okay so you think about the
process of music now right and I own a
studio now yeah so let's eliminate
owning the studio you have to book
studio time you have to pay the producer
you have to do the song you got to get
it mixed you got to get it mastered you
got to do the video you got to put it
out and hopefully and then you gotta
figure out a way to make money off of
that because you're already for people
who don't know 3 900 every million
streams on Spotify that's it so and you
have to hope that it accumulates that to
get your investment back versus I can go
downstairs and make three grand tonight
yo that's crazy so you know the urgency
of it is like you know I want to put out
[ __ ] that I feel is perfect you know
it's dope I don't have to rush anything
there's no fillers in there and we can
sit there and see if this the songs age
over time because a lot of the [ __ ] I
did with Canon some of them songs were
almost three years old but it still
stands up I mean Don Cannon's that guy
come on the production but that's the
difference with the production quality
yeah you know I mean like when you're a
real producer
you can make them Timeless records and
you can bring the Beast out of artists
and stuff how many understand something
they did because you know I'm from
Arizona I was just out it's my second
home you know I love Scottsdale you do
love you some Scottsdale I got to get
you to my new club bro congratulations
on that man wait wait you're doing it
with my with my guys um Cory Cory and uh
Davey on the guys they're my guys man
shout out to them yeah yeah I'll be out
there Thursday hey we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our family
at odd sucks that's right the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ]
world go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off Christmas time is it coming
and let me tell you something their
Black Friday sale if you're watching
this before Black Friday you might be
watching it after Black Friday but if
Black Friday hasn't came yet just like
Cyrus hasn't came yet it's been a while
he's on a drought guess what
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg 20
off plus whatever the [ __ ] else is going
on with their Black Friday sale and let
me tell you they got some new licenses
we got to talk about boys
my particular favorites
one of the greatest shows of all time
they got the Beavis and butt heads you
know what I mean and this is really a
big deal
The Big Lebowski that's right the
greatest movie to ever exist and shout
out to all you rappers and people who be
pouring your lean into this [ __ ]
some Mountain Dew Baja Blast socks
Casino great [ __ ] movie you know what
I mean these are pretty fly Bubblicious
yeah that's right a little Bubblicious
and this is the big one
big deal here
we got Coca-Cola socks baby that's right
Coke's on board
Coke is on board yeah I mean we get to
put the coke hat on
this hat doesn't work for me does it
doesn't work for me anyway you could get
you this hat though hey Cyrus take a
Coke hat there you go go to
oddsocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg right now save 20 off and go
purge their website for Black Friday get
gifts for your family your [ __ ]
family will love you if you buy them the
most comfortable socks in the world it's
that simple or you could buy them some
[ __ ] [ __ ] socks you could go buy
him some garbage ass [ __ ] ethica or
some [ __ ] ass [ __ ] Nike socks
[ __ ] them get Odd Socks let's get back
to the interview
you know I was I was eating at a
Filibertos at about 4 30 in the morning
last weekend and I thought to myself
for lab in La why is there no [ __ ]
real [ __ ] all-night food popping
isn't that [ __ ] crazy like I can't go
get a burrito at 4 45 in the morning in
L.A the taco trucks are all closed the
valley you can
where crave [ __ ] Crave Cafe where the
[ __ ] is that bro [ __ ] it's literally is
there a driver there's like three of
them out here is there a drive-through
no drive then [ __ ] out of here I want to
drive through and give me a [ __ ]
California Burrito at four in the
morning true and it's like it's L.A you
could post made it
the Great White Hut that they just
opened is it good
it's good enough because it's the only
[ __ ] thing you can get food from
guess what it's a drive-through no no
drive through there's a certain [ __ ]
about La that really bothers me because
it's LA and it should be like should be
booming it should be all night I should
be able to go get food
I should have more options than
Jack-in-the-Box is all I'm saying I know
I'd be trying to like let me hear him go
to the Hibachi truck before yeah man
open it all what do you I think if I was
telling us about this I was like bro I'm
trying to open up all night just 24 7
spot because I feel like it would boom
out here it would though because they
know there's nothing do you think
there's any like restrictions against
that that's why I don't do it I don't
know I just know I live in Burbank and
the Armenians be closing down early yeah
because I can't get nothing I gotta go
to Jack In The Box you live in Burbank
Jason are you worried about bringing
people to your house when you do the
stream no because everybody that I bring
like I trust with my life anyway and
everybody everybody okay
and it honestly honestly like I don't
live in in fear and if it has to go
there I'm prepared for it because I had
like a huge I bought a new house in
Burbank and I have like this huge
building behind my house and I was like
I could totally do the podcast right
here I was like well [ __ ] that [ __ ] well
that's kind of like what you know the
goal is now is to buy a compound and buy
a hub so we don't have to just bring
everything to your crib what's it like
uh you and pun have been rocking for so
long and it's dope to see pun kind of
become a personality too because he's
just been up and I was on accident too
exactly I mean he's been behind the
scenes for so long he's I mean I met pun
I think originally when he was working
with problem way back in the day
probably when Zoom alone that's when I
met him team alone problem yeah shout
out to pun but uh he's managing you as
well right
and he's been man I mean he was managing
you was uh when was that was it was
Adrian manager me and Adrian yep
swish swish helped me out
tremendously yeah when it comes down to
that's my brother always will be my
brother
um pum was one of the people that I I
appreciate continuing to rock with me
because I was not making this money for
a long period of time and he was still
[ __ ] with it and everybody was
telling him why the [ __ ] do you [ __ ]
with A.D so much right you know what I'm
saying he always told people hey when he
finally settles down when he figures it
out when he figures it out he gonna pop
he gonna do it the right way and you
know I'm just glad that now people see
like okay you had you had your eye on
the right person for sure man and you're
killing it I'm proud of you bro
just hope to see you I mean I [ __ ] I
watch your [ __ ] all the time man I
appreciate it bro I'm proud of you bro
I'm like damn this [ __ ] cab bro we
doing our thing man kill it I'm saying
new spot coming
yeah you know and uh you know I I yeah
I'm doing my thing yeah I mean but it's
it's dope to see what you're doing bro
and I think like uh the real [ __ ] the
sky's the limit dog you just gotta
[ __ ]
keep doing your thing keep pressing your
line oh bro I got especially for this
year I got so many uh things we about to
do yeah is it is it like weird going out
in public and getting recognized for
just being like a guy who talks [ __ ] now
I honestly like that [ __ ] yeah yeah you
know it like it really it really gets me
when I see like
a mom
don't know who I am and it's like her
her three uh teenagers running to me hey
D hey hey how you doing tomorrow they're
like okay you must be somebody right you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah that's a
beautiful thing man well listen I
apprecate you for pulling up bro make
sure you go follow my guy go watch her
at the end of the day go watch it at the
end of the big Community Watch we hungry
watch Community watch uh uh uh uh back
on fig Watch Ace boys worldwide watch
ladies night you know we building all
this stuff ladies night ladies night is
punching on Tuesdays man so shout out to
Barbie shout out to Ella shout out to
the person who had the [ __ ] Zoom
strip club going up during the pandemic
I remember I got in once and I was like
whoa did you go to the zoom strip club
no you wouldn't no he wouldn't no he
wouldn't only if it was men you know
what's crazy he told me one time you
guys always want to eat with women no
one wants to eat with me
oh my God I appreciate your brother man
appreciate you bro you already know boom